so trump's team had a press conference
yesterday where they laid out their
voter fraud claims
uh a lot of discussion in the media
afterwards has been
about the the the physical uh
spectacle of of of the of the press
conference rudy giuliani
was very sweaty apparently um he had uh
hair dye dripping down his face and so
that's been the big headline
that that was even the headline on on
the drugs report
and but here's the thing you know that
kind of thing that's what you focus on
the fact that he was sweating and maybe
he was hot in the room
okay i can sweat too so i'm not gonna
judge the guy for that
and you know he's wearing a suit that's
what this is one of the things as men
this is
this is a burden we care we have to wear
suits even matter what the temperature
is
that's the only formal attire we're
allowed to wear so uh
the fact that he's sweating or in hair
dye that's what you focus on
if if you're an idiot or if you're too
afraid to talk about the actual
substance
and in the media of course i think it's
sort of a bit of both a lot of idiots
a lot of people that are afraid to talk
about the actual substance as for the
substance
um many different types of allegations
were made it was
i think a 90-minute press conference
rudy in particular
asked i thought a number of salient
questions brought up a number of
irregularities we're calling them now
that need to be investigated
um and so that was sort of one one thing
um and a lot of that
i've been saying all along some of the
stuff that rudy was talking about
you know these these are these are the
things i think we should be focusing on
also
early voting mail-in voting
mass mail-in voting late ballots coming
in
i think these are the issues that that
no matter what happens with the election
need to get our focus and this is
something that
again no matter what happens 2024
if republicans don't resist this if we
if if this is what it's going to be now
forget about voter fraud for a minute
but if we're just going to have
mass mail-in voting early voting
you know where you can vote anytime for
six months up to the election um it's
it's going to be a total disaster
it's going to be what this has been
every single damn election cycle
something for republicans to keep in
mind um
so there's that part of it okay now we
could talk about that
and those to me are the sort of sober uh
not quite as dramatic or exciting
issues but important and then there's
sidney powell
who alleges no less than the greatest
crime in american history
i mean this is an absolutely sensational
claim that she's making
doesn't make it wrong doesn't mean it
doesn't mean it's untrue
sometimes sensational extraordinary
things are true
oftentimes they're not sometimes they
are but we should just be clear about
what she's actually alleging her
if it's true this is one of the most
significant things that has ever
happened in the country
and it's also the utter destruction of
our way of life of our democracy our
republic
it's been totally destroyed what she
alleges is that um
there was a plan to rig the voting
machines
and to switch millions of votes from
trump to biden that's what she says
again this is this is separate from
issues of
poll watchers not being allowed in
ballots being counted late
all that kind of stuff this is an
entirely different thing and here's what
that's what she's saying according to
pal trump
not only won but one in a landslide i
think she said um
i don't want to miss quota but i think
she she has she has said or speculated
that he may have gotten like 80 million
votes
now i i would say before we even look at
this that
that doesn't seem plausible to me take
voter fraud out of the equation
you know modern america i don't see
donald trump getting 80 million votes
i don't see any republican ever getting
80 million votes
i could be wrong but anyway so she
thinks trump wanted a landslide and that
the votes were switched
and um and the machine is key the
machine was rigged here she is talking
about it
i'm talking about some massive straight
lines up in the vote tallies
in the middle of the night after they've
supposedly stopped counting
and that's when the dominion operators
went in
and injected votes and changed the whole
system and it affects
votes around the country around the
world
and all kinds of massive interests
of globalist dictators corporations
you name it everybody's against us
except president trump
and we the people of the united states
of america we will not be intimidated
american patriots are fed up with the
corruption from the local level
to the highest level of our government
and we are going to take this country
back we are not going to be intimidated
we are not going to back down
we are going to clean this mess up now
president trump won by a landslide we
are going to prove it and we are going
to reclaim the united states of america
for the
people who vote for freedom so those are
the claims
um we haven't seen evidence of those
claims
we haven't she says she has the evidence
we haven't seen it
i mean you have not seen it if you're
watching this i haven't seen it
and speaking of which tucker tucker
carlson gave last night
uh i thought a truly great monologue
and i would recommend watching after
this show and after you watch all the
other daily wire shows then you can go
watch tucker carlson's model i thought
it was really it was it was
very good it was honest and clarifying
uh i think probably the most important
monologue that anyone has delivered on
cable news since the election which
maybe is kind of a low bar but still
that's where i would put it
it was very very good and he said that
um
powell hasn't even hasn't hasn't he
contacted powell's people
asked to see some evidence of this so
that he could you know
talk about it and she refused to give
the evidence
but also importantly and this is the
part i think we should focus on because
a lot of the focus has been on the claim
tucker made that powell won't show him
the evidence
more importantly tucker is saying that
powell hasn't even showed the trump camp
her evidence
so here's uh tucker carlson we took
sydney powell seriously we no intention
of fighting with her we've always
respected her work
we simply wanted to see the details how
could you not want to see them
so we invited sidney powell on the show
we would have given her the whole hour
we would have given her the entire week
actually and listened quietly the whole
time at
rapt attention that's a big story
but she never sent us any evidence
despite a lot of requests polite
requests
not a page when we kept pressing she got
angry and told us to stop contacting her
when we checked with others around the
trump campaign people in positions of
authority they told us
powell has never given them any evidence
either nor did she provide any today
at the press conference powell did say
that electronic voting is dangerous and
she's right we're with her there
but she never demonstrated that a single
actual vote was moved illegitimately by
software
from one candidate to another not one
so why are we telling you this we're
telling you this
because it's true and in the end that's
all that matters
the truth it's our only hope
it's our best defense and it's how we're
different from them
we care what's true and we know you care
too
that's why we told you maybe sidney
powell will come forward soon with
details on exactly how this happened and
precisely who did it
maybe she will we are certainly hopeful
that she will
what happened with the vote counting
this month and at the polling places in
detroit and the polling places in
philadelphia and so much
else actually matters
it matters no matter who you voted for
it matters whether or not you think this
election is already over
until we know the answers to those
questions conclusively and we can agree
on them
this country will not be united okay now
what this would mean is that
sydney powell is alleging she has
evidence that she
alone has evidence of the greatest crime
in american history and not one single
soul on earth has seen it but her
that is that's the situation we're
facing here now a few things a few
brief points i want to make first of all
tucker carlson whether you agree or
disagree with what he just said i don't
know how you could disagree with it
i mean all he's saying is we need
evidence for sensational claims
what what is there to disagree with
um but even if you whether you do or or
don't
the fact is he's getting a hell of a
blowback from his audience because of
this
he knew that he would get bo back from
his audience
and i just want to be very clear about
something here because i'm seeing some
of the claims on social media and
twitter
that people say oh tucker sold out he's
sold out
he's a grifter no no tucker carlson is
not a sellout and he's not a grifter
this is not how selling out works this
is not how grifting works let me let me
tell you how selling out and grifting
works from the perspective of
a conservative in the media which of
which i am one
um a sellout and a grifter
in conservative media is someone who
will never say
anything that will upset their own
audience
that's someone who always tells his
audience everything the audience wants
to hear and already thinks
pandering is another word for it a
sellout a grifter is someone in
conservative media or you know or or any
media for their own eyes
who will never upset their own audience
if somebody is going on in front of
their audience and saying something that
they know their audience will not want
to hear
and that may hurt their ratings and that
will bring in all the hate mail
say whatever you want doesn't mean you
have to agree with what they said but
you cannot accuse them of selling out
that is them being honest about what
they really think
and to punish them for it and say i'm
done with this person
you're done with them for being honest
with you
this you're gonna you're gonna punish
someone so so you want someone who's not
being honest
you're looking for someone gonna pander
to you and tell you exactly what you
already think
so that's the first thing you know there
there
there are a lot of conservatives in
media over the last four years who have
done
nothing but pander to their audience not
one damn thing except pander to their
audience
and a lot of them get the credit for
being the truthful ones
and the conservatives of media who will
actually be honest and upset their own
audience
on occasion they're the ones who get uh
blasted for being
dishonest and you know selling out and
all that it's exactly totally backwards
um so that's that's the first again in
terms of the claims i just go back to
you know we need to see the evidence
for it um there's no way you can accept
as gospel
as a claim this sensational without
seeing the evidence now you could say
well sidney powell has no
obligation to show us the evidence she
has to show it in court i absolutely
agree i've been saying this from the
very beginning
my take on this is bring your evidence
to court uh
i'm i 100 agree with that and i have an
open mind and
bring it to court and let's let's hash
it out um the only problem is that
if you don't want to provide the
evidence to the court of public opinion
if you don't want to provide the
evidence to
the media and in fact if you're going to
um if you're going to react almost
offended that the media would even
expect for you to provide evidence
then why are you in front of the media
every damn day
talking about the evidence you won't
show them so that's a problem cindy
powell's on tv
every single freaking day talking about
the evidence she refuses
to show anybody uh so you know if you're
if you're going to do that
if you're going to go in front of
someone and say i've got this evidence
of course they're going to say can i see
it
you can't that's oh how rude sidney
powell later came out and
responded to tucker and said he was
being rude and aggressive and
okay well it's it's a perfectly
reasonable thing you tell somebody you
have evidence of something they say can
i see it
um and then the second point is fine so
we gotta we gotta hash this out in court
fully on board with that
but there are a lot of people who are
repeating sidney powell's claims
as fact they haven't seen the evidence
there's no place for that
so um we'll see what happens and and and
here's
the final point if
sydney powell has uncovered the greatest
crime in american history
and is single-handedly going to save the
american republic
then she is one of the great heroes in
american history
um if however this is
a lie or scam then
she's one of the great villains in
american history it's kind of like one
or the other it's
it's one extreme or the other right now
that's what we're dealing with there
might be a little bit of room in between
but i think we're looking at one extreme
or the other
and we'll find out which one it is hey
you uh
yeah you you're right you right there
hit the subscribe button right now
do it do it right now i thank you for
your compliance
it's somewhat appreciated